Python dominiert die Programmiersprachen.
JavaScript wird am meisten genutzt und C wird wieder beliebter.
Jeder nutzt Git und React ist das beliebteste Web-Framework.
Aber warum ist das eigentlich so?
Und was solltet ihr am besten lernen im Zoo der Programmiersprachen 2023?
Es gibt zwei große Quellen, die uns Entwicklern einen guten Überblick geben, mit was unsere
Kollegen so arbeiten.
Die Stackoverflow-Umfrage und den TIOBE Index.
Beide sind natürlich nicht perfekt, aber es geht um eine Richtung, was euch demnächst
erwarten könnte.
Dieses Video hier habe ich übrigens auch schon die letzten beiden Jahre gemacht.
Dieses Jahr wird es deswegen ein bisschen anders.
Wir wollen darüber reden, warum Dinge so sind, wie sie sind und für wen jeweils was
relevant ist.
Ihr dürft dann selber entscheiden, wo ihr euch einordnet.
Ich werde noch den Vergleich zu den letzten Jahren ziehen oder zu vor allem den letzten
Jahr.
Das hier war trotzdem nur das erste von 5 solcher Videos, die euch in den nächsten
Wochen erwarten zu verschiedenen Themen.
Und passend zum Thema sehen wir eines, das zumindest meine Entwicklung in der jüngsten
Zeit komplett dominiert hat.
Chat-GPT.
Die KI, zu der ich schon ein Video gemacht habe.
Doch ich war zwischen Weihnachten und Neujahr nicht untätig, sondern an einer Entwicklung
mit einigen tausend Zeilen Code beteiligt.
Alles davon mit Chat-GPT.
Und meine Erfahrung möchte ich mit euch teilen bei der Job I.O. von Get in IT.
Das ist eine Jobmesse, die Get in IT regelmäßig veranstaltet.
Das nächste Mal am 26.01. um 14 Uhr und natürlich vollständig online und für euch kostenlos.
Dieses Mal ist das Thema Softwareentwicklung und auch ich darf einen kleinen Vortrag mit
euch teilen, direkt am Anfang.
Registriert euch deswegen schon jetzt.
Ich freue mich wahnsinnig auf euch und nutze am besten einfach den Link in der Beschreibung.
JavaScript hat wie auch letztes Jahr bei Stack Overflow den ersten Platz belegt.
Das heißt, was am meisten genutzt wird und zwar mit einem ordentlichen Abstand.
Die erste andere Sprache, die dann wirklich noch genutzt wurde, ist Python von über 20%
weniger Leuten im professionellen Umfeld.
Zum Programmieren lernen ist es allerdings die zweitbeliebteste Sprache.
HTML zählt nicht.
Spannend ist aber speziell hier der Vergleich zum Vorjahr.
JavaScript wird im Vergleich von weniger professionellen Entwicklern genutzt, während Python gestiegen
ist.
Die Erklärung, warum JavaScript so beliebt ist, ist aber trotzdem sehr einfach.
JavaScript ist die einzige Sprache, die wirklich für Websiteentwicklung im Frontend genutzt
wird.
Alle Frameworks im Webdevelopment Frontend werden mit JavaScript eigentlich benutzt.
Und auch serverseitiger Code für Webapps wird häufig mit JavaScript geschrieben.
Node.js führt tatsächlich sogar die Liste der Webframeworks kurz vor React an.
Das heißt, von allen JavaScript-Entwicklern arbeiten etwa die Hälfte auch im Backend
mit JavaScript.
Und sogar dort läuft JavaScript in mehr als der Hälfte der Fälle in Kombination mit dem
Express Framework, was die Arbeit mit APIs stark vereinfacht.
React hingegen ist das beliebteste Frontend-Framework natürlich auch in JavaScript.
Das zweite ist Angular, allerdings mit deutlichem Abstand und ein wenig später kommt Vue.js.
Spannend ist aber auch, dass gerade unter den professionellen Entwicklern ASP.NET Core die
20%-Marke mittlerweile geknackt hat und damit Vue.js im Vergleich zum Vorjahr überholt hat.
Hinter der JavaScript- und der C-Sharp-Fraktion kommt dann Python im Bettbereich mit seinen
Frameworks Flask und Django.
Da aber Python und C-Sharp im Frontend eigentlich nicht zu finden sind, kann man hier ziemlich
gut sagen, dass JavaScript immer noch die Sprache für Web 2023 bleiben wird, sowohl
im Frontend als auch zu einem großen Teil im Backend.
Denn es bietet sich einfach an, wenn man nach Fullstack-Entwicklern sucht, ihnen nur eine
Programmiersprache zu geben und dafür einfach zwei Frameworks, nämlich React zum Beispiel
im Frontend, Node und Express im Backend.
Werden die Teams aufgeteilt, also man hat Leute, die nur Frontend machen und Leute,
die nur Backend machen, dann hat man eher die Wahl.
Übrigens TypeScript als Add-on für JavaScript hat sich unter allen Programmiersprachen insgesamt
den Rang Nummer 5 erarbeitet, wobei davor auch SQL und HTML-CSS dabei waren.
Also von den reinen Sprachen ist es sogar auf Platz 3.
Spannend dabei, in der Umfrage, ob JavaScript geliebt oder gehasst wird, sagten nur 62%
dass sie JavaScript wirklich mögen.
Bei TypeScript waren es 72% und das macht TypeScript die drittbeliebteste Sprache bei
Stack Overflow.
Witzigerweise sieht's bei den Webframeworks komplett anders aus.
Beliebt sind vor allem Phoenix von Elexia, Svelte für JavaScript, ASP.NET Core und Deno.
Richtig unbeliebt ist dagegen AngularJS.
Leider sieht die Bezahlung im Webbereich auch nicht ganz so rosig aus.
JavaScript ist mit einem jährlichen Durchschnittsgehalt von 65.000 Dollar in den Top 10, allerdings
von unten.
Und richtig gut bezahlt wird hingegen Phoenix und Ruby on Rails.
Vielleicht ist das der Grund, warum Phoenix und Elexia so beliebt sind.
Auf Platz 2 hat sich aber wie auch im Jahr davor Python geschlichen.
Mit fast der Hälfte der Stimmen zählt mittlerweile definitiv auch Python zu den Must-Haves.
Gerade unter den Lernenden genießt Python eine unfassbare Beliebtheit.
Die Sprache ist einfach zu lernen und ziemlich flexibel, man kann sie fast überall anwenden.
Man findet Python im Webbereich etwas, aber vielmehr ist Python ein Allrounder.
Deswegen gab's auch im Tiobe Index den Platz 1 für Python.
Schaut man unter den beliebtesten anderen, also nicht den Webframeworks, findet man direkt
unter dem.NET Framework NumPy und Pandas.
Das sind wohl die beiden wichtigsten Bibliotheken für Data Science und Machine Learning.
Da.NET meiner Meinung nach schon fast eine Umgebung ist und der Platz 4 Spring eigentlich
ein Webframework ist für Java, holt sich Python also quasi die ersten drei Plätze,
denn nach Spring landet TensorFlow direkt auf dem nächsten Platz.
TensorFlow ist das Framework schlechthin für neuronale Netze und künstliche Intelligenz
und ist auch meistens in Python benutzt.
Nach Flutter, einem Framework für App-Entwicklung, kommt dann auch wieder was von Python, nämlich
Scikit-Learn und kurz darauf Kafka und PyTorch.
Alles Frameworks, die häufig mit Python genutzt werden.
Spannend ist hier aber der Unterschied zwischen den professionellen Entwicklern und denen,
die gerade Coden lernen oder ein Hobbyprojekt machen.
Professionell wird weniger NumPy eingesetzt, aber wenn NumPy, dann eigentlich auch immer
mit Pandas.
Kafka hingegen wird kaum gelernt, nur 2%.
Im professionellen Umfeld hingegen ist es aber deutlich häufiger vertreten als sogar
TensorFlow.
Das bestätigt auch ein wenig meine Beobachtung.
Python wird überdurchschnittlich häufig für private Projekte zum Lernen oder für
Dinge genutzt, die einfach Spaß machen.
Klar, professionell ist es auch viel im Einsatz, vor allem im Data-Science-Bereich, aber insgesamt
arbeiten einfach weniger Menschen als Data-Scientists als beispielsweise als Web-Developer.
Besonders interessant ist aber auch hier der Vergleich zu letztem Jahr.
Während die Data-Science- und Machine-Learning-Frameworks wie NumPy, Pandas oder TensorFlow im professionellen
Umfeld sogar etwas zurückgegangen sind, ist Kafka von gar nicht vorhanden auf fast 12%
gestiegen.
Insgesamt ist Python aber beliebt, auf dem 6.
Platz mit 67% der Stimmen, die sagen, dass Python eigentlich toll ist.
Allerdings ist auch Python, was die Bezahlung angeht, eher in der unteren Hälfte angesiedelt.
Spark und Kafka hingegen sind die beiden Frameworks, die am besten bezahlt werden.
Es kommt also bei Python wohl extrem darauf an, in welchem Bereich man arbeitet und wo
man Experte ist.
Wenn man sich allerdings in die Nähe der Hardware begibt, wird Python und JavaScript
schnell nicht mehr ausreichen.
Stattdessen blicken wir auf 20% C++-Entwickler, 17% C-Entwickler und sogar 4,5% die mit Assembly
arbeiten müssen.
Dazu muss man kurz sagen, dass hier auch Entwickler für beispielsweise Python-Bibliotheken
mit reinfallen, denn Python kann C-Bindings.
Das heißt, wenn ihr eine Python-Bibliothek schreibt, könnt ihr das auch in C++ machen.
Und auch wenn die drei eher im unteren Bereich der Beliebtheit angesiedelt sind, haben sie
doch eine gewisse Fanbase und einen ziemlich einzigartigen Anwendungsbereich.
Hardware-Bauteile programmieren, Firmware schreiben und das wahnsinnig effizient.
Denn auf so einem kleinen Teil, auf so einem Chip, passt einfach nicht so viel drauf.
Jetzt hat sich hier ja nicht wirklich was verändert zum Vorjahr.
Warum also die Erwähnung?
Ich vermute persönlich, dass in den nächsten Jahren und natürlich dementsprechend auch
2023 der Bedarf an hardware-nahe Entwicklung nach oben gehen wird.
Und zwar steil.
Smart Home und IoT wird immer mehr und wer weiß, vielleicht gibt's das ja auch bald
ein bisschen auf diesem Kanal hier.
Während allerdings der Bedarf an neuen Apps, zumindest bei mir als Konsument auf einem All-Time-Low
ist, ich hab gar keinen Bock mehr was Neues zu installieren, ist gerade einer der spannendsten
Standards für IoT rausgekommen.
Die Rede ist natürlich von Meta.
Und das muss aber noch implementiert werden.
Solange die durchschnittliche Bezahlung nur ganz knapp über der von Python liegt, müsste
mir persönlich allerdings jemand einen ganz besonderen Anreiz geben, mir Assembly wirklich
anzutun.
Aber genau das ist im letzten Jahr eigentlich auch schon passiert.
2021 war das durchschnittliche Jahresgehalt für Assembly 20.000 Dollar tiefer als heute.
Das sind über 25% Steigerung.
Fairerweise muss man dazu sagen, die Gehälter sind überall deutlich gestiegen, im Durchschnitt
sind das etwa 23% gewesen.
Dennoch steigt Assembly schneller als andere, was mir signalisiert, dass dort besonders viele
Entwickler gebraucht werden.
Wo wir aber gerade bei der Bezahlung sind.
Die höchste Bezahlung hat derzeit nicht Kobol.
Ich hab schon in ein paar Nachrichten von euch gehört, oder wohl gefragt, ob man irgendwie
Kobol lernen soll für bessere Bezahlung, aber don't.
Das will man wirklich nicht.
Stattdessen ist Clojure dicht gefolgt von Erlang auf dem ersten Platz.
Mit einem durchschnittlichen Gehalt von 106.000 Dollar pro Jahr ist Clojure wirklich gut bezahlt.
Zum Vergleich mit Python oder TypeScript seid ihr mehr als 30% schlechter bezahlt.
Phoenix als Webframework hatten wir ja schon, falls ihr LXE-Entwickler seid.
Am besten arbeitet ihr dann noch mit Chef als DevOps und habt richtig viel Bezahlung.
Die sind nämlich bei 120.000 Dollar im Jahr im Durchschnitt.
Und wo wir schon gerade von DevOps sprechen, da steckt ja Ops drin, das heißt ihr macht
auch Operations, also Server-Administration.
Haltet euch da an klassisches Server-Hosting, also Co-Location, nicht Cloud, nicht AWS,
sonst gar nichts.
Einfach Co-Location, da sind die Gehälter nämlich bei 111.000 Dollar im Durchschnitt
pro Jahr.
Das Ganze ist natürlich nur so halbernst gemeint, wir sehen hier allerdings einen gewissen
Trend.
Die Gehälter sind wahnsinnig gestiegen, das liegt aber nicht zuletzt an der Inflation.
Klar.
Aber auf der anderen Seite sind ITler auch wahnsinnig wertvoll für ein Unternehmen und
das wissen mittlerweile beide Seiten.
In einem Job, in dem man den ganzen Tag in Jogginghose im eigenen Zuhause bleiben kann
und sogar noch Spaß bei der Arbeit haben kann, sind solche Löhne wirklich angenehm.
Apropos Cloud und Daten, im Bereich der Datenbanken dürfte die Sprache SQL keine große Überraschung
sein, die ganz ganz vorne ist.
Die ist Standard und wird das auch bleiben.
Die sollte jeder können.
Viel spannender sind da allerdings die Database-Management-Systeme, das heißt die Dinger, die eure Datenbanken
verwalten, die Software hintendran.
Und hier ist das erste Mal ein anderer auf Platz 1 zu sehen.
In den Jahren davor war immer MySQL die meistgenutzte Datenbank.
Dieses Jahr ist das im professionellen Umfeld PostgreSQL und das zu Recht.
Wir nutzen sie auch und einen Vergleich habe ich bereits gemacht.
Keine Änderungen gab es bei den Plätzen danach.
SQLite, MSSQL, MongoDB, Redis, MariaDB.
Beliebt sind aber vor allem bei den Leuten, die sie wirklich benutzen, PostgreSQL und
Redis.
PostgreSQL stinkt immer mehr ab, was vermutlich für viele auch ein Grund für den Wechsel
ist.
Am unbeliebtesten ist allerdings IBMs DB2.
Lasst uns aber mal nach dem Newcomer für dieses Jahr Ausschau halten.
Dazu werfen wir zunächst einen Blick auf den TIOBE Index.
Denn da gibt's so schön Plätze, die einfach angezeigt werden.
Im Vergleich zum letzten Jahr haben sich die ein kleines bisschen verändert.
PHP ist nach oben gerutscht, weil es eine neue Version der Sprache gibt, die ziemlich
viel moderne Sachen mitbringt.
Und Go, Matlab, Rust und Objective-C schleichen sich auch einige Plätze nach vorn.
Objective-C vermutlich deshalb, weil Swift insgesamt gefallen ist und die beiden im Apple-Kosmos
ein bisschen das Entweder-Oder sind.
Spannend für mich also an Sprachen sind vor allem Rust und Go.
Lustigerweise genau die Sprachen, die bei mir im letzten Jahr auf dem Lernzettel standen
und dieses Jahr auf dem Tutorials-Zettel stehen.
Und das deckt sich übrigens auch mit Stack Overflow.
Rust ist nun das siebte Jahr in Folge die meistgeliebte Programmiersprache und mittlerweile
wohl auch wirklich in einem stabilen Zustand, in dem sie auch von 8,8% professionellen Entwicklern
schon verwendet wird.
Go hat sogar noch ein paar mehr professionelle Entwickler mit knapp 12%, trotzdem nicht ganz
so viele Fans.
Man muss hier aber auch wirklich sagen, dass die Anwendungsfälle sich schon ziemlich unterscheiden.
Rust konzentriert sich auf hohe Performance und zeigt gleich eine niedrige Fehlerquote,
wenn der Code läuft.
Es ist das Ziel bei Rust, dass wenn der Code läuft, dann soll es am besten fehlerfrei
sein.
Das heißt, schon bevor er ausgeführt wird, kann man das meiste im Debugging machen.
Und das ist natürlich super, wenn man einfach Sachen rausbringen kann, die wahrscheinlich
nicht abstürzen.
Trotzdem soll aber auch die Geschwindigkeit und das Umfeld mit dem von C++ verglichen
werden und das macht die Sprache besonders als Nachfolger im hardware-nahen Umfeld interessant.
Go ist ebenfalls eine kompilierbare Sprache, allerdings mit Fokus auf Web, Cluster und
Cloud und Skalierung.
Das sind beides wichtige Themen in der nächsten Zeit und dementsprechend glaube ich, dass
beide Sprachen auch nächstes Jahr wieder ein bisschen ansteigen werden.
Allerdings, was Arbeitnehmer können und welche Technologie im Unternehmen benutzt wird, das
bedingt sich oft selbst.
Trotzdem kann man sich zumindest bei der Wahl der Technologie ein bisschen vorbereiten,
da man sonst ohnehin umschulen muss.
Im DevJobScanner wurde eine Analyse des Jobmarkts durchgeführt für ITler bzw. für Entwickler.
Nicht nur arbeiten die meisten Entwickler mit JavaScript.
Auch 29% aller Jobangebote sind für JavaScript-Entwicklung.
Das ist fast ein Drittel.
Python macht etwa 18% aus, also immer noch ordentlich viel.
Klassisches Java mit 15,8% auf dem dritten Platz, C Sharp 12%.
Danach kommen PHP und nach C, C++ und Ruby wird's wirklich dünn.
Das insgesamt, also diese Sprachen decken nämlich schon mehr als 95% ab.
Alles in allem können wir also mitnehmen.
Die meisten von uns arbeiten im Webumfeld und arbeiten mit JavaScript und all den Frameworks,
die dann dazukommen.
Python ist nach wie vor überall.
Rust und Go sind auf dem Vormarsch, genauso wie Kafka, das auch im Webbereich eine große
Community mittlerweile findet.
Wenn ich so mit euch spreche, dann bestätigt ihr mir all das.
Desktop-Apps sterben aus, dafür werden Websites und Apps weiterentwickelt bzw. neu entwickelt
und wir werden allesamt überdurchschnittlich gut bezahlt.
Zumindest wenn wir nicht selbstständig sind.
Gleichzeitig fallen aber auch die meisten Jobs auf nur vier Programmiersprachen.
Die sollten sich also definitiv in eurem Repertoire befinden.
Diese und auch die meisten Frameworks oder nischigeren Technologien findet ihr bereits
bei mir als Tutorial.
Geht dazu am besten direkt auf die Bootstrap Academy, um da mal reinzuschauen, die ist
übersichtlicher als YouTube.
Ein paar Sachen fehlen mir allerdings noch.
Zum Beispiel Kafka.
Deswegen meine Frage an euch.
Was sind eure Technologien für 2023?
Welche Sprachen wollt ihr unbedingt lernen und vor allem welche Technologien auch?
Schreibt mir das bitte in die Kommentare, denn meine Tutorials richten sich immer stark
nach dem, was ihr euch wünscht.
Und vergesst vor allem nicht, nächste Woche geht's weiter mit den wichtigsten Technologien
fürs neue Jahr.
Bis dahin, ciao.